I think it is popular in the US I think
the problem it I'm een you can just look
at a World Cup anytime there's a World
Cup going on people stop and watch no
matter if it's on 4:00 in the morning or
or not you know it 10:00 at night
whatever people find a way to make time
to make that happen so it's just kind of
plugging into that kind of passion I
think we have a lot of euro snobs here
in this country that don't want to give
our league a chance they just think well
they all the other leagues in the world
are better and you know in some fashions
they are but you know we're coming along
here and this in this league I'm very
excited to be a part of it I think the
future is very bright and we it's just
converting the soccer fans that already
that already exist here I think we try
to convert I think initially our soccer
our fan base was more like soccer moms
and their kids and I think when you
watch a game overseas you don't see
soccer moms and kids in the stands you
see you know 18 to 49 year old males in
there you know enjoying themselves quote
unquote enjoying themselves and you know
cheering and having a good time being
passionate about their team and it's
just going to take time to build that
and I think what's unfair is that we
could get compared to the other
professional leagues in this country
that have been around for 50 or 60 years
have had iya you know much greater head
start in terms of you know working out
their kinks and trying to figure out
where they're going to fit in the
National landscape them you can even go
back to the NBA in the 70s I mean it
didn't they didn't start blowing up
until Magic Johnson and Larry Bird came
around you know and so and then once
rivalry started and you had this history
and I mean our league is this will be
our 13th year and it's just going to
take time to build a fan base but also
to develop a rivalries in history you
know I mean if you watch sports center
they have stats from like 80 years ago
that don't matter but they have them and
so and people are interested in them
it's just like that use are not so
useful information they get stuck in
your head and you know we're just going
to take time to kind of get to that
point and when that goes hand in hand
with our development as a league as our
players as the next generation of kids
grow up and and grow up and say you know
I watch Landon Donovan play
I watched Cobi Jones play and these are
real things because when I was a kid
there wasn't any of that and so it's
very important for kids just to not know
any different than the major league
soccer and once those kids grow up and
say you know what this is what I want to
do this is what I want to be I want to
play for that team it's going to it's
going to fit in nicely in our national
landscape
[Music]